welcome to the lifespan podcast where we
discuss the science of aging and how to
be healthier at any stage of life
I'm David Sinclair I'm a professor of
genetics at Harvard Medical School and
I'm co-director of the Paul F Glenn
Center for biology of Aging research
this podcast series is about why we age
and why we may not have to things you
can do today
and going forward to increase your
wellness and to potentially live a much
longer healthier life
we've talked about the biology of Aging
we've talked about things that you can
do at home preferably under the
supervision of your doctor and today
we're going to talk about things that
you definitely will be talking to and
requiring a doctor's supervision to do
and even things that your doctor
is unable to do but potentially in the
future may be able to
I'm joined today by my co-host and my
co-author the lovely Matthew LeBlanc
amen
we're back we're doing it again we are
definitely doing it today we're doing a
deep dive into some you know somewhat
controversial stuff this is a scary
episode
uh well I don't know if it's scary but
we have to do a disclaimer I think we
have to say that what we're going to
talk about today
um a lot of it isn't approved by the FDA
but maybe in the future and some things
that were available until recently and
were banned by the FDA and are currently
available only offshore and just as was
the case when we had the conversation
about drugs and supplements uh and maybe
even more so in this case
um there's a lot of misinformation out
there about a lot of things that we're
going to be talking about today these
potential avenues for addressing
longevity we're going to try to cut
through that
um but we are not doctors of the
physician type that's right I'm a PhD in
genetics I'm not a physician and so the
things we've talked about in this series
should always be done with the
supervision and advice from your
physician yeah podcast is no substitute
for a physician that's right but I'm a
scientist I can read the scientific
literature can distill that down you're
a science communicator and we're here to
be able to distill the wealth of
information that's out there and
distinguish what's fact from fiction and
give people you know a starting point as
to really how do they figure out what's
best for their wellness and what's
actual complete bull out there and so
today we're going to be talking about
stem cell therapy peptides exosomes
testosterone growth hormone and then
we're going to spend a little time
talking about one of your favorite
subjects epigenetic reprogramming but we
can't do that until we do something else
first well we need to thank the sponsors
who make this podcast freely available
our first sponsor is athletic greens the
all-in-one daily drink to support Better
Health and Peak Performance
athletic greens is a greens powder
developed from a complex blend of 75
vitamins minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients
it's filled with adaptogens for Recovery
probiotics and digestive enzymes for gut
health there's also vitamin C and zinc
citrate for immune support
I've been drinking athletic greens every
morning for a few years I really like it
because I travel a lot and I don't often
eat perfectly and I can rest assured by
drinking athletic greens I'm getting
everything I need for Optimal Wellness
and health
so if you'd like to try athletic greens
you can go to athleticgreens.com
Sinclair to claim a special offer
they're giving five free travel packs
plus a year's supply of vitamin D3 for
immune health and vitamin K2 which keeps
the calcium out of your arteries and
puts it into your bones where it's
needed again go to athleticgreens.com
Sinclair to claim this special offer
today's podcast is also brought To Us by
inside tracker inside tracker is a
personalized nutrition platform that
analyzes data from your blood and DNA to
help you better understand your body and
reach your health goals I like inside
tracker because they present the data in
a really clear form and the nutritional
advice is really actionable and has been
shown scientifically to improve many
blood biomarkers and if you're not
looking at what's going on in your body
you'll have no idea whether what you're
doing is actually working or not working
another feature that inside tracker has
is their inner age test this test shows
you what your biological age is and you
can optimize that they also make the
test really easy to take you can have
people come to your house to have your
blood drawn or you can go to a local
clinic so if you'd like to try inside
tracker you can visit insidetriker.com
Sinclair and you'll get 25 off any
inside tracker plan use the code
Sinclair at the checkout today's podcast
is also brought To Us by levels levels
is an app that syncs with A continuous
glucose monitor that they provide and
interprets your glucose data for you
I've been so impressed by levels that I
recently joined them as an advisor by
monitoring your blood glucose levels
allows you to see how different foods
impact you
I've been really successful at impacting
my blood glucose levels positively I
found that foods like grapes Spike my
glucose and potatoes don't do so much
so that's really important because I
don't get those highs anymore followed
by a crash which leads to a brain fog
and lethargy so if you'd like to try
levels you can skip the 150 000 person
wait list and join today by going to
levels dot link Sinclair that's
levels.link Sinclair
all right let's Dive In by starting
today with testosterone super popular
subject lots and lots of growth in
testosterone replacement right now be
because of the fact that testosterone
decreases as we age and that's
disconcerting to a lot of people
oh for sure after the age of 30 to 40 we
lose about one percent about
testosterone levels men and women it's
important for both sexes
the market has grown so trt or
testosterone replacement therapy has
grown from a few hundred million 10
years ago to multi-billion Dollars now
it's it's widely used not just to
supplement for sexual dysfunction which
is a common side effect of low
testosterone but for other things that
include mental health building muscle
overall Fitness vitality and people
swear by this a lot of people did they
do this they say they feel younger they
say they feel more vigorous they want to
have sex again they want to have sex all
the time there's an important
distinction to make here though which is
just because you feel younger does not
necessarily mean you are reversing your
biological aging
right let's make a clear distinction
we've talked about adversity mimetics
and in the last episode we talked about
the supplements and the kind of things
you can do in your life to mimic that we
want our bodies to be in a state of fear
that times are tough and they need to
hunker down and survive
there are other types of things that
we're going to talk about which are
abundance memetics testosterone is one
we're going to get to growth hormone as
well these tell the body that times are
good to build your muscle to reproduce
go forth multiply and that's what
testosterone is doing we get
testosterone replacement therapy we are
putting a substance back into our body
that has been reduced but which signals
our body that times are good enough it's
okay to build muscle it's okay to run
around chasing woolly mammoths yeah
chasing the cave women around exactly
yes that for sure and that benefited our
ancestors very well
uh but it didn't help them long term
what we now appreciate is the body has
cycles of of want and need and adversity
which is good for the long-term health
of the body and times where things are
abundant times to grow reproduce which
are great short term but probably not
great for long-term Health and Longevity
either okay so let's talk about what
actually happens when our testosterone
lowers and what happens importantly when
we put it back because this is helping a
lot of people with a lot of problems
that are coincidle with aging oh for
sure there have been a lot of studies
millions of dollars and and many
thousands of people treated with trt as
it's called
Shelley Basin who's a colleague of mine
at Harvard has done a lot of these
studies and he's found some improvements
short-term improvements so of course
improvements in libido but also he shows
a dose-dependent increase in skeletal
muscle mass so you get bigger muscles
you've got more power you can climb
stairs you can walk further in six
minutes improves aerobic capacity these
are all good things that he sees but but
actually it's not all good news there
are some side effects and may actually
impact longevity so some of the risks of
trt there's worse sleep apnea you can
actually get larger breasts let alone
factors your testosterone can be turned
into estrogen which is a risk for men
particularly you can have what's called
benign prostatic hyperplasia so bigger
prostate need to go to the bathroom at
night shrinking testicles not something
I think many of us would want and
increasing red blood cell protection
which could lead to blood clots and if
you're already predisposed of prostate
cancer you have cancerous growth already
this could actually aggravate the tumors
yes um and actually the the opposite is
true if you look at the history of Unix
they live longer and so it may actually
be that supplementing with testosterone
is not conducive to longer life okay so
this is an important principle here and
we're going to come back to this a
couple of times on this episode which is
just because something makes you feel
good today and just because it might
even be medically beneficial to you
today that does not necessarily mean it
is do it is addressing the causes of
biological aging it may be fixing
something that you have a problem with
it may be improving even your quality of
life right now
long term that's not the same thing as
as reducing or eliminating biological
aging yeah let's go back to the main
Concepts here today which are that
adversity adversity mimetics are great
things that mimic lack of food and a lot
of exercise but these abundance mimetics
are probably a problem long term even
though they make you feel great short
term okay and that's sort of giving away
the punch line for HGH but we need to
talk about HGH as well
um human growth hormone also something
that is really popular right now people
uh supplementing with human growth
hormone to address things like uh
decreased Exercise capacity uh decreased
bone density decreased muscle mass and
increase body fat this works right for
for those things this HGH is helpful
well no question uh short term you'll
you'll feel better you'll grow muscle
you'll have less fat on growth hormone
therapy the science says that this may
not be good for long term Health and
Wellness going back to the original
studies of Cynthia Kenyon which we
talked about in episode one those mutant
worms had low levels of growth hormone
and insulin-like growth hormone
signaling and they lived longer twice as
long and this has been reproduced also
in mice and even in humans there are the
Laurent dwarfs we were talking about
earlier these are smaller people that
have low levels of growth hormonal or
actually igf-1 one of the versions of
this pathway
they are relatively resistant against
cancer and heart disease and may even
live longer
conversely if you're supplementing with
growth hormone long term the chances
that you're having the opposite that you
feel great but long term you might have
even greater risk of cancer and heart
disease and you know people who are on
HGH for various reasons one of the
immediate side effects even before we
get to sort of like the longevity
implications is uh sore joints carpal
tunnel syndrome right this is the kind
of thing that that does happen now I
just want to be clear there are some
benefits to bringing the levels back up
to normal okay but going too high which
a lot of people do if they want
additional benefits that's where I think
the the main risk comes from another
risk immediate is increased insulin
resistance that's true we get high
levels of blood sugar we get high
cholesterol carpal tunnel edema so
buildup of fluid uh joint pain Okay so
soreness in your joints insulin
resistance uh another one is an increase
in the likelihood of type 2 diabetes
because of that insulin resistance all
of this actually kind of sounds like
symptoms of Aging right and that's the
risk that the animal studies are telling
us that growth hormone will tell your
body that times are good
abundance memetic and that's not good
for long-term effects of health and
probably what's going on is some
acceleration of Aging okay but this
isn't to say again I think I think this
really we don't want to say human growth
hormone is bad testosterone is bad
people need to have a naturally healthy
level of these hormones in their bodies
and there are ways to do that naturally
so for testosterone you can work out the
bigger muscles in your body and that
also help with growth hormones so I I
work out my thighs and my back
particularly keep those nice and strong
and I've found my natural testosterone
levels go up to normal levels with that
so that that's a way to do it with
growth hormone it's all about eating at
the right time and sleeping so if you
eat not too close to sleep time and then
you rest through the night and have a
good night's sleep that's the best way
to improve your growth hormone levels
and if you're doing all of that and
you're still struggling to keep these
levels up that's the time to talk to
your doctor about supplementation but
that supplementation needs to be aimed
not at hyper increasing the levels of
these in your bodies but just keeping
them at that sort of like that Natural
Healthy level well exactly but I would
encourage everyone to try it naturally
first so so far this sort of feels like
bad news because these are things that a
lot of people have gotten in their heads
might be beneficial to anti-aging and
what you're saying and what the evidence
suggests is that there is no anti-aging
benefit there might be a short-term gain
not a long-term anti-aging benefit
um but these aren't the only things that
are sort of like
hot on the market right now another
thing that's really popular to talk
about really popular to try uh where it
is legal is peptide supplementation yeah
so peptides just like hormones are made
of strings of amino acids but typically
smaller about 100 amino acids you can
synthesize them on a machine or extract
them from tissues and they're used by
cells to communicate between each other
so your brain will put out peptides to
Signal the body your liver and your
muscle and some of these are really good
some are really bad
we don't know what they all do there are
probably a thousand made by the body
we've probably only know about what 20
of them do in great detail well we what
we do know is as a class the the help
cells communicate to one another right
and so just sort of like holistically
speaking into oh that's really good
because
in part aging is the loss of cellular
communication and so peptides help
increase that cellular communication
voila
they must be great for aging well again
it's whether you're an adversary
adversity mimetic or an abundance
memetic that's the difference and really
you have to make a distinction between
those two things
one of the best studied peptides of all
time is insulin and clearly that's
important if you're deficient in it
we've known this since the 1920s that we
actually have a hundred euros now is a
1921 which was when insulin was first
discovered right Banting and Best in the
was in 1921 found they could extract
this insulin extract from the pancreas
of a dog and injected into a dog that
had diabetes and cured within hours and
within months they were trying this on
human beings because that's how things
worked back then yeah and they even won
Nobel prizes quicker it was only one or
two years afterwards that they won the
Nobel Prize for that so they went from
this works in dogs to let's try this out
in a 14 year old boy
to Nobel Prize in the span of like two
years well it was worth it because in
those days particularly type 1 diabetics
which are the is the childhood version
of this
the lack of insulin meant that they
would have to go on it the kids would
have to go on a starvation diet and even
then they would die within a year or so
it was horrific and suddenly people were
living for decades that first patient
lived for another 13 years and so this
set us down the road of studying
peptides and their health benefits
um and then a really big thing happened
in the 60s which is we figured out how
to synthesize peptides right that was a
big deal
um and then in 1978 they started to be
made using recombinant DNA technology
and that's why we find ourselves today
is that most of these hormones and
peptides that are available on the
market are made using recombinant DNA
technology though these very small
peptides are unique because you can
synthesize them on machine which makes
them very cheap didn't you you say like
there's like some people have these
machines at their homes yeah I'm aware
of some people that have them and
they're making them at home and
injecting themselves I don't recommend
that that's
currently uh that's off label use of
drugs and you don't want to do that but
that gives you an idea how it possible
it is to make a drug these days
especially these peptides because these
are at this point so easy to synthesize
and because they're relatively cheap and
because they are relatively non-toxic
there's been lots and lots of clinical
studies on on the use of peptides right
thousands of human studies and and it's
interesting why why are they so safe
well they're not foreign they're
typically already found in the body and
they're small so they don't typically
have an immune reaction though the risk
is not zero they metabolize quickly
they're also metabolized quickly and so
the risk is relatively low and for that
reason there are a number of doctors who
have been okay giving these peptides to
patients and what we're looking for when
we give peptides to people specifically
for the cause of anti-aging is a boost
of regenerative signaling right so what
you're looking for is the ability to
recover from damage increase wound
healing lower blood sugar levels
increase mitochondrial activity those
are examples or signatures of an
adversity mimetic not an abundance
memetic okay let's talk about some of
these
um we have discussed in the past might
see right mozzi matsi so mots C that's a
really interesting peptide an unusual
class that actually doesn't come from
the nucleus that normal chromosomes that
we talk about but from the mitochondrial
DNA in mitochondria and up until about
10 years ago we thought that there were
only 13 genes encoded in the
mitochondrial genome and there are now
about a hundred known and motzi is
probably the best characterized of those
there's another one called human as well
motzi when injected into mice lowers
blood sugar levels increases
mitochondrial activity gives you the
signatures of long life probably
promotes life there's some evidence of
that and has been in humans in fact
there's a clinical trial that was just
released the results of which showed
that it reduces fat in the body and
improves fatty liver which are again
signatures of potential longevity and so
so your belief at this point is that
there are likely peptides that are
valuable when it comes to addressing the
causes of biological aging unlike these
other things we've talked about today
well almost certainly but we don't know
enough yet to say for sure if that these
are perfectly safe or will increase
lifespan a lot less is known about these
peptides than testosterone or growth
hormone and to that in the FDA
agrees they're nervous well yeah because
they became so popular typically on the
west coast La there's there was a real
Mega Trend and still is up to try these
out and they have a variety of
properties that seem to be beneficial
anecdotally improving memory muscle mass
lowering inflammation
the FDA looked at this and said whoa
hold on we don't know enough and they
sent a letter to a company saying stop
making this and then that sent
shockwaves this was March of 2020. and
uh and so since then it's been
impossible to get some of these peptides
in the United States because they've
stopped compounding them right so even
though there have been some promising
results with peptides the FDA has said
some of these need to be regulated and
many of them now you cannot get in the
United States so they're still in
clinical studies researchers are still
examining them but the Avenues for
getting these in the United States have
become more limited there are still
people getting them overseas compounding
them in their own machines at home right
uh but still we have to be careful
because they they're not all perfectly
safe and one of the reasons the FDA was
nervous about this and ban many of them
is that there are some side effects
um it's not just that they can be
redness where they're injected but
actually it seems like you can induce
arthritis type effects when the immune
system recognizes these peptides as
foreign and that would be something you
definitely wouldn't want to have as an
immunological reaction a lot of these
have names that are like Star Wars
droids
um and so people have heard these
um heard of these they might wonder what
they're doing uh one that's really
popular in conversation right now is
bp157 yeah bp157 is one of the more pop
popular ones it's been used to increase
blood flow lower inflammation and even
regenerate neurons for cognitive ability
but there are lots of others there's one
called ss31 which targets the
mitochondria and improves mitochondrial
function could seem to be good for the
heart maybe for longevity there's
another popular one called ghk copper
it's part of a copper complex was first
identified in human plasma later which
is found in saliva and urine and it's
been used to help wound healing attract
immune cells it's an antioxidant
stimulates collagen protects tissues
against inflammation can even be used
apparently to reduce Fine Lines wrinkles
and grow hair again
there's a whole bunch is this based on
I mean is this anecdotal evidence is
this research-based evidence how do we
know these things about these different
peptides yeah most of these come from
Mouse studies and then they're ant total
from from studies that that clinicians
are currently doing but yeah again I
want to stress that most of these things
that we're saying are anecdotal and not
yet scientifically validated these are
some people's experiences and and this
is all one of the reasons why there is a
pretty significant movement right now
this sort of like save peptides movement
of people who are contacting the FDA and
saying please make these things more
available to us again well yeah there's
one in particular thymus and Alpha one
which has been known since the 1970s to
be beneficial it seems to be great
particularly for helping against while
fighting bacteria and viral infections
but it was also listed on the the banned
substances in 2020 and there's a
movement to bring it back because with
covid-19 it's thought that it could help
talking about other ones that some of
these work with fat loss apparently
we've got tessemoralin CJC 1295 is taken
with one called epamorolin there's
aod9604 and the bpc-157 again can be
good for for weight loss apparently
one of the other ones I mentioned human
is again one of those mitochondrial
derived peptides like mozzi and in mice
at least it's been shown to help against
type 2 diabetes high blood sugar
cardiovascular disease and even help
with neurodegenerative diseases like
Alzheimer's but in humans it's not clear
if that's true
pineal on is a really interesting one
it's actually an active peptide complex
and has been thought to treat memory
attention deficits brain injury stroke
chronic fatigue Etc but again early days
we don't know for sure if this is
actually true in humans and then finally
we should just mention there are others
that are being used to combat fatigue
and also boost the immune system they go
by names like dioxa cerebral lysine
Cemex selling or even bpc157 is used
with somax and cerebellisin together
again these are all pretty much
experimental they've been shown to be
effective in mice but still we have a
long way to go before we know if they're
truly effective in humans and they're
there we always need placebo-controlled
double-blind clinical studies which are
underway I mean there are lots and lots
of clinical studies going on it's just
not moving as fast as I think a lot of
people would really like it to move but
that's that's the reality of the space
that we're in right now well it is and
and often it is frustrating and I can
speak from personal experience how long
it takes to make a drug can be extremely
slow and we're all getting older we're
not getting you know in in the case of
most of us we're not getting any younger
and there is a a desire to rush into
things but I think we need to exercise
some caution here because you can have
these negative side effects particularly
in the case of peptides and immune
reaction that could be deleterious in
the long run and in that long run though
you see these as a a very promising
Avenue for a lot of therapies that are
going to help a lot of people Inc not
just with individual conditions but you
think with aging official not all of
these of course but those that mimic
adversity might see is a good example of
one that I think has the right signature
I think they have a lot of Promise
because there is uh an explosion of
research going on sort of at the same
time with peptides and this other thing
that we're about to talk about exosomes
I think these happen in the same breath
uh a lot of times people talk about
peptides and exosomes
um both of these are cellular signalers
but exosomes work well they are
different and they work a little
differently or very different these are
packages of information they contain
well they membrane bound so they're
little Vehicles about the size of a
virus so they travel between cells and
into cells very easily and inside it's
not just one message there's multiple
messages there's peptides inside there's
DNA there's RNA even what are called
micro rnas which are similar to peptides
very small pieces in this case of
nucleic acid material that can go from
the brain to other tissues from tissues
back up to the brain and this is
essentially the way the body can
coordinate so if there's an injury on
your hand your brain will know or if
your brain gets injured the rest of your
body knows you need to have these
Messengers to coordinate the system in
the same way you could imagine that the
US Post and so these are little mail
deliveries or cargos that we can both
intercept and read perhaps we can use
these to diagnose diseases including
cancer but also we can make more of them
and Infuse them into people to give a
false alarm perhaps even to simulate
this adversity and make us live longer
and before we get to those therapeutic
processes one of the really fast-moving
uh avenues for using exosomes is
basically collecting them from the blood
counting them up and being able to
diagnose different injuries and even
like you can pull from people's blood
these exosomes and then you can say like
oh they have an injury here they have a
disease there right yeah there are
companies now that uh there's one um
cold Czar Therapeutics there are others
that you can read the cargo and you can
say okay that comes from the pancreas
that is the signal signature of a stage
three pancreatic cancer so we we may be
able to use these to diagnose cancer
years in advance without biopsying right
just a blood test or even a finger prick
at home send it off and diagnose cancer
and that that would be reason enough to
be excited I think about the potential
for exosomes to tell us what's going on
in our bodies but what else we're
learning right now about exosomes is
that uh if we supplement these into the
bodies of mice like by injecting them
into their back into their bloodstreams
uh it can help with injury yeah I mean
there's there's a really well-known
paper now from August 2017 by my good
colleague down at Albert Einstein
College of medicine medicine dong Shan
Kai and his expertise is looking how the
hypothalamus the little organ at the
base of the brain communicates to the
rest of body and he's found that
inflammation in and damage to that part
of the body affects the rest of the
animal including aging and in this case
he found interestingly that neuronal
stem cells these progenitors in the
hypothalamus they secrete exosomes that
tell the body to hunker down and survive
and the mouse can actually live longer
if you isolate these exosomes and give
it to the mouse they also did the
opposite they deleted these special
cells that make the exosomes and the
mice got diseases of aging and lived
shorter what why is that happening well
we don't know in most cases there's so
many things within the exosomes so we
it's very hard to figure out which of
those particular cargos is responsible
for the biological effect but ultimately
if we can figure that out we could make
exosomes with just that particular
component and that could be a drug in
the in the future there was another uh
fairly recent paper on exosomes uh 2019
paper from some Chinese researchers uh
that used exosome replacement to address
ulcer healing and what they concluded
was that the exosomes were actually
rejuvenating senescent cells
really fascinating here well that was so
senescent cells if you missed the
previous episode are cells that as they
get old and they have X differentiation
they lose their ability to read this
their DNA correctly they become
senescent they stop dividing they sit
there and they start secreting
inflammatory molecules can even cause
cancer to develop
we try to delete these cells we know
that in a mouse and probably in a human
if you get rid of these inflammatory
senescent cells it's good for health but
here we're saying what the researchers
are saying is that these exosomes the
particular type of exosomes can reverse
in essence that's unheard of if that
turns out to be true that would be quite
a remarkable thing meaning one day we
don't have to kill off these cells which
you know in the brain you wouldn't want
to do that necessarily we could actually
rejuvenate them and get them to grow
again healthily right now the way we
understand how to do that is through the
yamanaka factors but this would be
another Avenue toward that same goal of
taking X differentiated cells and
sending them back into a differentiated
State well the yamanaka factor
Rejuvenation of senescent cells is
preliminary this is some of the work
we're doing in my lab and it's not even
clear if the Yemen archifectas are
potent enough to reverse senescence but
this finding that you refer to is the
first instance that that might be
possible all of this is is why there's a
lot of excitement around this uh this
particular potential therapy but again
just like peptides this is sort of the
Wild West right now but people are
already
taking exosomes and and having them shot
into their bodies they can be delivered
by IV or intramuscularly but again we
don't know what the long-term benefits
or side effects are so we have to be
careful it's still available in some
parts of the US but we don't know yeah
this is not one of those things you have
to go to Costa Rica for at least as of
right now the FDA hasn't cracked down
they haven't said this is a step too far
that's right but well while exosomes
aren't completely banned in the United
States you can bet that the FDA is
looking at this for uh potential safety
concerns and we'll see how things go
over the next few years that's not the
same thing as saying like go do it now
no no that's not what we're here for uh
we want to educate and look at what
might be available down the line once
things have proven to be safe and
effective and this is another one of
those things like like peptides you're
feeling
um positive that there is going to be
actual clinical research that will show
us the actual benefits of these we don't
have to make super super guesses we can
actually see in the research how
exosomes are going to be beneficial and
then start to implement them into our
longevity regimes in a responsible way
that's right and just to be clear
exosomes are a highly validated
scientific Pursuit and there are biotech
companies pharmaceutical companies
building giant factories for billions of
dollars to make exosomes to treat
diseases
the question is do they work for
long-term Health and Longevity and how
safe they are to be you know used over
decades that we don't know yet okay
let's move then into an area of research
that is even further along
um still we're learning more about every
single day
um but also has potential anti-aging
implications stem cells let's start with
a little primer stem cells are stem
cells are cells that can divide
asymmetrically to produce cells that go
on to make tissues so for skin you need
stem cells to make all the skin that
grows over your lifetime and they retain
youth so that they can keep dividing
over and over and they don't
become any particular certain cell type
over time and stem cells can become more
stem cells or they can become any kind
of cell and there's a few different
types right the two main classes are
multipotent which can make a few
different types of tissues these are the
cells that you typically get from an
embryo or you can go all the way back to
h0 and what are called pluripotent stem
cells which can make any type of cell in
any type of tissue you can think of this
sort of like as as one of those trees
right like like you have the pluripotent
cell that can do anything and then after
a while a little further down in the
development you have the multipotent
cells which are still able to
uh transition into
several different kinds of cells but not
all the different kinds of cells exactly
and so if you want to build a mini human
brain or rebuild a kidney out of a skin
cell you have to wind the clock all the
way back to zero and start again and
that's called inducing a pluripotent
stem cell State and that goes back to
what we were talking about earlier the
yamanaka factors this is one of the ways
that we've identified that we can
turn a stem cell or any kind of cell
from being a stem cell back into a state
of pluripotency yeah let's just talk
about shiny yamanaka because it's really
quite an amazing story so yamanaka in
Japan in the early
well 2010s was in his lab was figuring
out or trying to figure out how do you
take an adult cell from an animal or a
human and make it pluripotent because if
you could do that imagine you could
build any tissue you wanted and he was
trying lots of different Gene
combinations and hit upon five genes
that when put together worked to take so
I could take your skin cell Now using
yamanaka's genes or yamanaka factors and
make a pluripotent stem cell line and
rebuild you I could even turn you by the
way into a sperm and an egg and clone
you but I won't do that so yamanaka
found the following genes so klf4 socks
2
cmic and Lin 28 we use three of them
particularly in my lab we'll talk about
that later OS and K for short but this
was a major breakthrough because finally
you could take anybody's skin cell which
you could easily get from the cheek or
biopsy grow that in a dish
look or reprogram them which takes about
a week once you put these genes in and
when they grow up into what we call a
colony which is an assemblage of about
100 cells you pick those and now you
could grow basically anything you want
from from matte or plant cells well and
I've seen this in your lab where you've
taken cells from a mouse you've induced
them in those data pluripotency and then
you have uh trained them for lack of a
better word to grow into uh brain cells
and now you have these little clusters
of brain cells that look like little
brains well we've done that for mice and
we've done that for human we have many
human brains and we take these from old
individuals old normal individuals and
also patients that have susceptibility
to Alzheimer's disease and uh again we I
think I want to talk about this later
but what we'll we have the ability in my
lab to drive aging forwards in those
what are called cerebral organoids and
even in reverse and that's what's
important really for being able to study
the human brain without having having to
touch patients and we can go a lot
quicker that way before we we sort of go
down that rabbit hole can it take us
back just a couple of steps to how this
actually happens like how do you take
these factors and put them into a cell
what's actually really easy any high
school student could do it uh there are
a number of ways the the old ways of
doing it or you can pass electricity
through the cells in the dish and they
take up DNA that encodes these yamanaka
genes you can put them in what are
called liposomes or liposomes which are
fat membrane-bound little bowls but the
way we do it in the lab which is the
most efficient is we use viruses
domesticated viruses that are typical
quickly used in patients for gene
therapy we use them in the lab they're
called adeno-associated viruses or aavs
we package inside those the yamanaka
genes and just throw them into the dish
and they infect all the cells in the
dish and now those cells are transgenic
they carry these genes and we can turn
those genes on and off at will using
drugs and see what happens
and the employee
here is that we can take these uh these
now pluripotent cells and then we can
use them to treat areas of the body
where the cells just aren't acting the
way that they're supposed to act anymore
but there's still a problem with
pluripotent cells right or sorry induced
pluripotent cells right now and that is
cancer yeah if you take the age of a
cell back to zero and allow it to just
grow and put it if put it into a mouse
and probably a human you'll get cancer
teratoma is a picture particularly
pernicious type of cancer which can be
you know hairy ball of mass sometimes
with teeth in it you don't want that so
you have to be very careful not to put
these pluripotent stem cells back into
the body and just let them grow
which is why right now most stem cell
therapies aren't using induced
pluripotent stem cells they're using
harvested stem cells and we can get
those from a variety of places right
mainly what we're using what scientists
and doctors are using are what are
called autologous stem cells so but
cells that you take out of your body
from various parts of the body typically
fat cells on your back or your hips and
then purifying them out freezing them
down and or putting them back into the
body in different places or into the
bloodstream so if we could just suck
stem cells out of fat out of adipose
tissue a lot of people don't think like
well why would we even go through the
process of trying to induce pluripotency
if we can just take stem cells out of
fat but one of the things that I think
needs to be said and you've done some
research on this is that stem cells age
also they do they undergo epigenetic
changes that make them
less able to regenerate new tissues and
that's also true you see that with gray
hair and and hair loss that's the loss
of the stem cells in the hair follicle
one other thing that would just happen
recently is it was discovered that you
don't just have stem cells getting old
they keep can even be kicked out of
What's called the niche where they where
they belong they like to reside and
that's true for the hair cell it was
there's a fascinating video that I threw
up on Twitter and the stem cell you
could see they captured it under the
microscope it got kicked out anyway it's
suffice to say what what is really going
on is that these stem cells need to be
uh slowed down in the Raging process or
even replaced and we're only just
learning how to do that the other thing
that we can do is capture them at a much
younger State that's where cord blood
comes in right and you can even do that
for for adults the idea is that if you
capture these cells when they're very
young or if you're in your 20s and 30s
you can Bank them put them in a freezer
for later use either to replace the
blood if you have leukemia or even using
new technologies to modify them and grow
new tissues
perhaps even replacing old blood when we
get very old and a lot of people are
doing this now
um it's becoming uh more and more common
for people to say hey look I want to
preserve my child's ability to use those
stem cells later on even if we're not
exactly sure how they're going to be
used and so they're banking them your
kids are and their teens and early adult
years
but if you could go back in time would
you do this yeah we didn't do that
because at the time it wasn't clear if
they would be useful but now it's very
clear that there are uses for them
especially if they get Childhood Cancer
and so I would do that if I was a new
parent I would aim to bank those how
about you uh yeah I mean so as you know
I haven't followed you down every
longevity rabbit hole that you've gone
down and that other people have gone
down but this is definitely 100
something that if my child had been born
today I would absolutely do I would be
banking their their Core Blood yeah so
if I did want to do that now though how
would I go about how would I go about
doing that well there are companies you
can contact and often the hospital and
the doctors you work with know how to do
this but you need to get ready you at
least need a few days off in a week to
get ready for this because you need to
spin them down and put them in a freezer
but when you when you have a placenta
there are particular parts of the
placenta you can take the court blood or
you can take a a thing called Wharton's
jelly which is this gelatinous substance
made of hyaluronic acid where there's a
particular concentration of stem cells
you can also isolate we can also isolate
stem cells from adults again these are
stem cells that have you know gone down
their trajectory from pluripotency often
to multi-potency and so they're not you
know they're more aged but the earlier
we do this the better right yeah these
stem cells in adults don't just age and
become dysfunctional they can
out-compete each other they can grow
faster if you have mutations in genes
like tetone type 2 dnmts they grow
faster and can actually out compete the
rest of the immune system if you look at
100 year olds often they only have one
or two instead of thousands of types of
immune cells which is a real problem if
they get pneumonia it's often why these
elderly people don't survive in
infection so what you might want to do
is to bank these HSE motor poetic stem
cells when you're younger so you can
replace your immune system as you get
older however we obtain the stem cells
uh researchers are using them for all
kinds of uh diseases they're being used
to regenerate and repair disease and
damaged tissues in people's spinal cord
injuries type 1 diabetes Parkinson's
disease ALS Alzheimer's heart disease
stroke Burns cancer arthritis and the
reason why I'm saying like making this
big list is because now thanks to what I
mean like really you've done this to me
anytime I hear a big list of diseases
and One Singular thing that can address
all of those diseases I don't think of
those diseases separately anymore I
think of aging and there's a lot of
implications here for the potential to
use stem cells perhaps to treat aging
and a lot of people like these other
things we were talking about are really
excited about this potential Avenue for
for anti-aging well they do have a lot
of potential first of all we can make
new organs using these induced
pluripotent stem cells or IPS sees and
even these autologous stem cells we're
talking about that you can pull out from
children and from adults they can be
used to replace stem cells that get old
but there's a real fundamental drawback
to using stem cells to live longer and
that is that they often don't find their
Niche their their resting place even if
you inject them into the eye often they
don't find their their home and in fact
one of the problems was when researchers
did this to patients in Florida there
were three people who became blind when
it wasn't done correctly so there are
that coincided with an FDA order that
said hey everybody
slow it down be careful you can get some
stem cell therapies now but the majority
of them have been banned for now but
what is really a problem is that if you
can't get them to the right place
they're not going to regenerate
rejuvenate the whole body so what we're
looking at now is how do you rejuvenate
the existing stem cells and stop then
getting older or even reverse the aging
of the stem cells in situ where they
exist and we'll get to that but this is
the reprogramming technology that should
work not just on normal cells but even
stem cells to make them young truly
young again all right and there's been a
lot of research showing that stem cells
can have a therapeutic effect in like
specific parts of the body but when we
talk about this like aging umbrella in
general uh there was one study actually
two studies a phase one study to phase
two study from researchers at the
University of Miami in 2017 that gave
stem cell therapy
harvested stem cells from younger donors
gave them to older frail patients and
and
small scale but it showed improvements
in the distances that these people could
walk it lowered the levels of cytokines
it improved their mental state and they
had a reported quality of life
Improvement as well yeah I mean that's a
remarkable couple of studies if it can
be reproduced but for now what most
people are using the mesenchymal stem
cells for is in joints when you wear out
the joint and there's not a lot of
collagen injections of stem cells into
those joints seems to be at least
therapeutic for a short amount of time
whether or not it's because the stem
cells stay in there or they're secreting
exosomes or other peptides it's unclear
so this is another area of research then
that
um again probably people don't want to
just walk into a clinic tomorrow and get
a stem cell injection because like you
said the stem cells might not even know
where to go but
in the future this is likely to be part
of people's common anti-aging regimen
well I'm sure I think the future looks
like this that we can keep our bodies
healthy by eating right doing physical
exercise taking the right medicine
supplements and when that doesn't work
and things fail you can then rebuild the
body replace cells put in new organs and
that way we'll live probably many
decades longer than we can currently
live and then there's one more thing
that in the future we may be able to do
and this leads us to this thing that
you're doing in your lab right now
um if you had quite a few published
studies on that are pretty darn exciting
we're talking about cellular
reprogramming well this is the big one
um we've been working for many years on
slowing aging but we've wondered how do
you get that to be reversed is there a
reset switch in an old cell and we think
we found it uh we're we're standing of
course on the shoulders of shinya
yamanaka who showed you can reset the
age of a cell back to zero but that of
course causes cancer and if you do that
in a mouse it'll die within days so
that's not going to be a therapy anytime
soon I don't recommend it but what a
wonderful student
um one Chang Liu did a few years ago in
my lab was he found a set of genes
um there are yamanaka factors that were
able to reverse the age of cells and
tissues in an animal and in human cells
to a certain point going back about 80
percent of age but not to zero so that
this was a new safe approach to
reversing the age of the body without
any negative side effects and he did
this by instead of using all five
yamanaka factors he used three of them
three and the the cmic which is the m we
definitely don't want that in there or
Lynn 28 these are what are called
oncogenic genes cancer-causing genes so
we left those out and surprisingly those
other three O S and K for short worked
not just in cells in the dish but even
in the whole animal we focused on the
eye because we thought reversing
blindness would be pretty cool and could
be a drug a very quick drug to develop
relative to the whole body
um and it worked one Ching uh sent me a
text of an of a picture of an eye where
he also regenerated the optic nerve that
was crushed and then he went on to
restore Vision in mice that were given
glaucoma which is pressure in the eye
and even restore
eyesight to Blind old mice and let's
slow this down a little bit and take
people through the process because we've
gone from like you know yamanaka factors
to restoring eyesight and mice let's
talk about first the conditions that
we're trying to be fixed were damaged
optic nerve cells and you used aavs
these delivery viruses to send these
three yamanaka factors into the cell
once they were there what started
happening well to be clear our genome
has the yamanaka genes in it but they're
normally only turned on when we're
little embryos so we had to reintroduce
those three genes with a system where we
could turn them on at will and we were
using an antibiotic to turn them on
called doxycycline we injected them with
the virus into the eye it's a it's a
very simple procedure in fact a lot of
patients that are blind get this
treatment already with other drugs so it
doesn't hurt only takes 10 minutes we
put into the eye of the mouse we damaged
the eye and asked could those
reprogrammed eyes that we reprogrammed
for a month could they regrow and the
answer was yes and not only did they
regrow but these mice that were
effectively blind that were blind
you can do a little tests and you can
see that their eyes actually work like
young mice eyes again well we put
pressure in the eye to mimic glaucoma
which is a major cause of blindness in
the world or we just let the mice age
out to one year of age and they they
were blind essentially and we could tell
that they were blind because we show
them little images that move lines
actually that move from left to right
and if a mouse can see that young mice
will move their heads it's called the
opto motorists you can see videos of
this is really cute they're like
watching the tennis match yeah we do
that too by the way uh we also of course
we measure the electrical activity of
those nerves we also measure the age of
those nerve cells we look at which genes
are switched on and off and the
conclusion was that the nerves went back
in time back to the reset full reset to
about 80 their genes the gene expression
patterns as we call it which is which
genes are on and off was reset to being
young again and the mice got their
Vision back is almost as good as they
were when they were young so a lot of
people hear this and say man this is
really cool you can reset blindness in a
mouse or reset vision and a mouse
can we do this with other cells yeah it
turns out that it's not just nerve cells
that can be rejuvenated and sent back in
time we've done this for skin cells
we're doing it for muscle cells we've
done it for other parts of the eye and
in fact that the shape of the eye and
the structure of the eye it doesn't just
go back in time it actually rebuilds
itself like it's young again so we're
super optimistic that this may be a
universal mechanism of age resetting in
the body that cannot just be applied to
different Mouse tissues but also in
humans as well and we're in the process
hopefully in a year year and a half of
trying to restore Vision in human
patients that have lost their vision due
to either glaucoma or genetic diseases
so this is happening because it's
accessing the backup copy the original
state of
the the genetic code that the cells are
building themselves up by well the
genetic code stays the same the
epigenetic code which is the reader of
the DNA which we talked about in episode
one that gets reset so the structures of
DNA folds that have gone awry during
aging this x differentiation process
where cells lose their identity
that gets reset back to youthfulness
but how that happens how do you get a
loop of DNA to go back go back into a
bundle and a bundle to go back into a
loop we have no idea how that works we
know that there's a backup copy of not
the genome but the epigenome the
structures that read the DNA similar to
polishing the scratches on a CD with the
analogy we talked about in episode one
but how does the cell do that how does
it re-establish that original software
and reinstall the software in the cell
we're only just trying to figure that
out now eventually we will know how this
works and maybe we'll even develop a
pill instead of a gene therapy that
could reset the age not just of the eye
but the whole body and when that happens
certainly it's going to be a very
different world but until then we'll
work on vision and then we'll see where
we go from there this suffice it to say
there are several ways that we think
that we can get the human body to do
this to to reset the epigenetic clock
um we can do it through cellular
reprogramming it looks like is possible
to do through exosomes
and you just mentioned pills and it does
appear that it's possible that this is
what metformin is contributing to and
some of the other drugs and supplements
that we talked about uh in an earlier
episode but I I mentioned metformin
because a lot of people are going to say
okay all of this stuff is great you've
told me a bunch of stuff that probably
won't be accessible to me anytime soon
there is
a treatment regimen that is being tested
out right now
that starts with metformin but a couple
of other
elements as well let's talk about that
yeah this is uh my colleague Greg Fahey
Dr Greg Fahey and he's been working on
uh anti-aging or longevity treatments
for a while and he hit upon a triple
treatment he uses growth hormone uh
which is known to raise blood sugar
levels we talked about that as a
downside but then he realized if he
could include DHEA a hormone that is
depleted during aging as well as
metformin he could mitigate the negative
effects of growth hormone and he gave
that for 12 months to 10 healthy men
that were aged 51 to 65
and lo and behold when he looked at the
biological clock of those men they went
back two and a half years which may not
sound like a lot but as I thought about
it if you could truly reverse your age
every year by one year that means you're
not going to age all right something
that confuses me about this combinatory
therapy regimen that that Fey he used in
this small scale uh trial is that it
takes advantage of human growth hormone
which earlier in this episode we said
probably not a long-term anti-aging
benefit so what was the idea do you
think behind using HGH well HGH had been
shown previously to reconstitute the
thymus this is a little
organ gland that's here in your chest
that is important for the immune system
is where your T cells your immune cells
come from and growth hormone can
stimulate the Regeneration of this as it
degrades over time I'm age 50 I'll
probably have a what's called a lot of
thymic degeneration and involution it's
you know a Vestige of what it used to be
and growth hormone can can stimulate
that but it comes with side effects as
we mentioned
um not least of which is increase in
insulin insensitivity or glucose
intolerance in other words the cell
doesn't take up the glucose from the
body when you have a lot of growth
hormone around so he combined that with
two
diabetes therapies one it is metformin
which everybody knows and Greg also
showed actually in an experiment that he
did on himself the DHEA this hormone
that some people take for longevity can
also control blood glucose levels so
that combination of three gave the best
effect but I should say that measuring
the clock in the blood doesn't mean the
whole body is being rejuvenated that's
just one indicator so what I'd like to
see Greg and his colleagues do is to
measure aging of other tissues and
measure it using different clocks not
just the Horvath or epigenetic clock we
talked in an earlier episode about the
proteomic clock there are a variety of
clocks there's glycan age which are
sugars that are attached to proteins
that change over time and there's one
called immuno age you measure various
changes in the immune system all
together these can be used to get a
better picture of whether Greg's
treatment is truly reversing aging or
just some aspects of it but the really
frustrating thing is even with these
clocks right now
we don't know what we don't know five
years 10 years 20 years down the line so
it's a really good indicator if we can
get these clocks to reset if we can get
these clocks to to lower like like Greg
did at least in the short term in the
long term do we have to wait for the
long term well it depends I know that
Greg's research is ongoing and it I I
was with him a couple of months ago and
he told me that repeated treatments over
more than a year actually reduce Age
based on this blood clot even more so
and people are going back by a decade
apparently so super interesting time I
would say the jury's still out whether
this is truly reversing aging or just
some aspects of blood aging but it's a
very interesting time that we live in
where people are ostensibly going back
in time one of the commonalities I think
in almost all of these things that we've
talked about today is there are these
early indications that something might
have effects and people are jumping over
one another to get to them and
um you know I mean some people are going
overseas if they can't get it here
they're finding doctors willing to do
this they're you know Finding suppliers
from wherever on the internet they can
and it's it's understandable right
because people are suddenly awakened to
this idea that aging may not be
something that we have to tolerate in
the long term so they're eager but
they're still
there's still work that needs to be done
there is but what what I think is really
exciting is we wrote our book lifespan
in 2018-19 and we envisaged a future
where people could turn their clock back
and be rejuvenated it's only been a
couple of years since then and there's
been huge a huge advance in the ability
to reprogram the body to measure it
um these tests are now available to the
public to measure biological age from
blood and and from spit
we're in an age where I would say it's
hard to even predict where we'll be in
five especially in 10 years from now but
if you're frustrated if you're really
over eager there are
things I think this this needs to be
said like you can take steps right now
you don't have to necessarily be taking
peptides and exosomes and you don't have
to you know hunt down Greg and say you
know like give me this this combinatory
therapy
just slowing down the biological clock
right now doing the things that we
talked about in the first few episodes
is going to buy you that time for these
therapies to
to mature to the place where we know
that there's a we know what they're
going to do right so stay young stay
alive because the future looks bright
um just with the current pace of
Medicine
and medical Technologies if you live an
extra year you get another three months
of life we could easily approach a time
where every year you live you get
another year of life and that's when the
world becomes super interesting what are
we talking about next episode we are
talking about aging on the outside so
we've talked a lot about how to keep
your insides Young
next episode we're going to talk about
your skin your hair your nails how to
keep those looking good and it's not
just superficial it's really important
it's actually been shown that if you
look younger on the outside you're
probably Young on the inside too so stay
tuned for that if you're enjoying this
podcast and would like to support us
please subscribe on YouTube Apple
podcast and Spotify on Apple you have
the opportunity to leave us up to a
five-star review
also check out the sponsors that we
mentioned at the start of the episode
that's probably the best way to support
the show
we also have a patreon account that's
patreon.com David Sinclair there you can
support the show at any level you'd like
thanks again for joining us on this
episode of the lifespan podcast